>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Good afternoon and welcome to the
African and Middle East Division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb.
I'm Chief of the division and I'm
really happy to see you all here
and I'm happy that we're
having this presentation
with the genealogist
Daniel Horowitz.
This big section is cosponsored
with the Jewish Genealogy Society
of Greater Washington and we thank
the society and its President,
Dr. Alpert and its members
for their cosponsorship
and their continuous
interest in our division.
In fact, last year the Genealogy
Society was also here in May 2016.
It was also there for the program
on The Blumenthal's of the Upper
and Lower Peninsula of Michigan,
so we had a program that sort
of preceded you in doing this.
As most of you already
know, our division is made
up of three sections, the
African, the Middle Eastern,
and the Hebraic section and we cover
responsibilities for the collections
from 78 different countries
in Africa, the Middle East,
Central Asia, the [inaudible]
we go off almost to China
and sometimes depending on
the collections we represent.
We also invite scholars and
experts who have researched
and done work here at the library or
elsewhere and who are knowledgeable
about areas that we know more
generally about and they know more
about as experts themselves.
Genealogy of course, is of great
importance here at the library.
We actually have a whole
division that deals
with local history and genealogy.
The library's genealogy
collection began as early as 1815,
with the purchase of
Thomas Jefferson's library.
Our digitized materials
on US history for example,
include first person accounts
of 19th century California,
the upper Midwest from 1820 to 1910,
the Chesapeake Bay area from 1600
to 1925, and other resources
for genealogy research.
We also have bibliographies,
and guides, and local history
in genealogy and we have programs
such as this one that
focus on genealogy.
And so now, our very
own Sharon Horowitz,
no relation I've been told,
the Senior Reference Librarian
in the Hebraic Section,
will introduce Mr. Horowitz
and the program, after which
you will be enlightened on how
to research here at the library
and Dr. Alpert will
also say a few words,
but first let me call
on Sharon Horowitz.
Thank you.
>> Thank you Mary-Jane.
Welcome to the African and
Middle Eastern Reading Room.
On behalf of the Jewish Genealogy
Society of Greater Washington
and the Hebraic Section, let
me thank you all for coming
to today's program in celebration
of Jewish American Heritage Month.
As you heard, I'm Sharon Horowitz
and I'm Reference Librarian
in the Hebraic Section.
The Hebraic Section marks it's
beginning in 1912, with the receipt
of 10,000 Hebrew books and pamphlets
whose purchase was made possible
by a gift from New York
philanthropist Jacob Schiff.
From those humble beginnings,
our collections have grown
to around 250,000 items in Hebrew,
Yiddish, Ladino, Judeo-Persian
and other Hebraic script languages.
The Hebraic Section also includes an
important collection of books in Gz,
Amharic and Tigrinya, the languages
of Ethiopia past and present.
Our section's holdings
are particularly strong
in the subject areas of Bible and
Rabbinic, liturgy, Hebrew language
and literature, Responsa
and Jewish history.
Two of our missions in this division
are to publicize our collections
and to bring people
into the library.
One way we accomplish this second
goal is by holding lectures
and having programs such as the
one we are hosting here today.
Before I introduce today's
speaker, it is my pleasure
to call upon Dr. Eugene Alpert,
President of the Jewish Genealogy
Society of Greater Washington
and one of today's
program's co-sponsors
to say a few words
about the society.
>> Thank you Sharon.
Even though it was
stated that Mr. Horowitz
and Sharon Horowitz are not
related, you never know [laughter].
I went through my life saying
I wasn't related to Herb Alpert
until I started doing
genealogical research.
Although I don't know for sure our
families came from the same town
in Belarus so you never
know [laughter].
It is my honor to be here
today and to thank the Africa
and Middle East division of the
Library of Congress for helping
to sponsor and support
the celebration
of Jewish American Heritage Month.
I represent the Jewish Genealogy
Society of Greater Washington.
We are a non-profit
organization founded in 1980.
Our mission is to help
people discover, document,
and share their Jewish
family history.
We have over 300 members.
We meet about once a month
with a special program
and Mr. Horowitz was there
yesterday to talk about his work
with DNA testing through my
heritage and we do help people
to help find their relatives
around the world using DNA,
or using research, or using
personal family recollections.
We have some membership brochures on
the desk over there in the corner.
I have one up here so you can always
contact us through wwwjgsgw.org.
You're really in for a treat today
because you're going to be hearing
from someone who has given so
many different presentations
on so many different
topics in genealogy.
I know Daniel will
be probably swamped
after the presentation today.
He is like a walking encyclopedia
of genealogy so you're really going
to enjoy the presentation.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Dr. Alpert, and
now a word about our speaker.
Mr. Horowitz was a teacher and
study guide editor for 15 years
of the Family History Project,
Searching for my Roots in Venezuela.
He was a Founder of the Jewish
Genealogy Society of Venezuela.
He has a BSC in computer
engineering, a specialization
in education, and a
degree in the management
of educational institutions.
He's employed at My Heritage
since 2006, where he works
in product development, customer
support, and public affairs,
and he speaks at conferences
around the world.
A resident of Israel since 2005,
Mr. Horowitz is on the Boards
of the Israel Genealogy
Research Association
and the International Association
of Jewish Genealogical
Societies and others.
One item of business
before we begin,
this event is being videotaped
for subsequent broadcasting.
There will be a formal question
and answer period after the lecture
at which the audience is encouraged
to ask questions and offer comments.
Please be advised that your
voice and image may be recorded
and later broadcast
as part of this event.
By participating in the question and
answer period, you are consenting
to the library's possible
reproductions and transmission
of your remarks and on your chairs
you'll find a flyer about our blogs
and Facebook pages from the
international collection,
so I urge you to look at them and
subscribe because you'll be amazed.
There are very wonderful things that
are being put up on that website.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Mr. Daniel Horowitz.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, thank you very much.
It's really a pleasure and
an honor for me to be here
after such a wonderful presentation
introduction and I really hope
that you will learn today more
than about my own personal family
but the ways and the
tasks that I did in order
to find them and to research them.
I'm going to start with just this
very first screen and you can see
in the back a family
picture, a family picture
that probably we all have and we
recognize from different houses
of relatives that we have visited.
I was very young, some
day I was very young yes,
and I saw this picture
and I actually started
to ask who these people were.
Who is this one, and who is this
one, and how they are related,
and how I am related
to those individuals.
I learned very fast that
this is my Singer family
and immediately I turned out to
the salon and I see this object
in the middle and I say,
"Oh, so we should be famous.
Probably we created this machine"
and for many years I was
very proud in secrecy.
Still, some day I asked
and they said, "No,
this belongs to the other family.
Well yes, your mother's side of
the family, they were tailor's
and your grandfather used this
as work", so I very fast learned
that we should ask about any
object that we have in our houses
because there are histories
hidden within.
Immediately of course, in
my mind I made a connection
so my mother's family
which are from Romania,
Chabotaro's [phonetic] are connected
to my Singer family who has come
from the Ukraine, through
this machine.
Wonderful story.
And then I discover
a lot of paperwork.
Paperwork made by hand
many, many years before
by my dear Uncle Lotter
[phonetic] from England.
By the time I discover this
paperwork and I realize
that all this scribbling are
actually names, dates, and places,
my Uncle Lotter passed away
and because I was interested
in all this family history,
all this paperwork passed to me
and I'm pretty sure, it wasn't
that long about but until today,
the first contact people had
with genealogy is in this way,
probably in a napkin in a
restaurant or a family gathering
when you start collecting names,
dates and places and you think well,
there should be a better
way to do that than
in this blank piece of paper.
Well yes, there is for sure and I
started using computers, technology.
I started to type the names,
and the places, and the dates.
The technology also allowed
me to take the pictures
of these individuals so they were
coming alive with their faces
over there and of course,
the technology allowed
me to make discoveries.
We are discoveries.
For example, my great grandfather
David Mayer Singer [assumed
spelling] was married to
Bertha Singer and of course,
you would say well
obviously, Bertha took the name
of her husband when she married.
Well no, she was Singer-Singer.
Hmm, so when I actually put this
into the family tree I realized
that they were actually cousins.
Their parents were brothers and
really, with a very wide family tree
in paper was almost
impossible for me at the age,
I was probably 20 years old,
very difficult to realize
that these were the same people.
So of course, I took more interest
in this and I just took my pen
and paper, camera, audio recording,
video recording, everything I could
to interview my relatives and ask
questions, questions about things
that I already knew but I had to
reconfirm, things that I had no idea
about it and I wanted to know more,
and things that may not be
even related and were only
in my mind and in my fantasy world.
Some of them were confirmed indeed,
some of them unfortunately
were not real.
We didn't belong to
the Singer family
that had the sewing machine
company, no money there.
So, when websites came up, I also
posted my family tree in a website
and that allowed me to share with
other people and allow people
to see my research and to tell
me of course that I was wrong
so they thought, but I kept
both whatever I have researched
and also what they told me and I
have then many dates and many places
and many names for the same
person until I found the paperwork
or I made the proper research.
I kept all my doors open.
But that is a way to collaborate
and to find new individuals
until one day in 2013, as
you can see over there,
I received this weird email
from somebody called Sattinger.
Okay, and Michael Sattinger tells
me that he picked on my family tree,
he saw a few of my dead
individuals that are not privatized
in my family tree, and he
thinks that we are related.
Of course, I get very
excited at the beginning,
I went to the family tree,
I tried to find those names,
I found some similarities but of
course I said, "I'm sorry Michael,
but yes, your people came from the
same city Czernowitz in Ukraine
from my family but so far I
cannot prove that we are related."
But then, Michael sends me
back and email and says, "Well,
I did further research and I am
attaching a naturalization paper
where you can see all the
relationships between the Singers
and the Sattingers and this is my
great-grandfather David Sattinger,
then the name and the dates matches,
came out with Haymen Sattinger
[assumed spelling] his grandfather"
and he tells me a little bit,
but this is what he sent me
and this is actually the
first contact that I have
with a paper trail in the US,
Petition of Naturalization.
I had no idea what this paper
was about but of course,
I started to read it and
I learned a lot of things
about not only this person
but his family and I found
out that David Sattinger
indeed was born in Romania,
was married to Bertha Singer (not my
great grandmother but another one)
and of course names repeat
across the family tree
so that was already a clue.
I see other family left back
in Czernowitz, I see where
and how they immigrated to America,
no America was the name of the ship
and they came from Hamburg
1913, naturalization intentions,
petitions, numbers, couldn't find
out what that was for now but then,
I have two signatures on
this document from witnesses
and one is Max Singer,
restauranteur in New York
and the other one is Samuel Singer,
also restauranteur
with two addresses.
Well, by that time I was
already a very techy guy,
of course very nice handwriting
signature of this person
but I have these two addresses so
what I immediately did is going
into Google, put those
addresses into Google Maps,
and find out very soon
how this house looked.
I still am not sure if this is my
family but this is nice to have
to see the house where they may
have been living over there.
So of course, by now I'm all
excited and I send an email,
"Michael this is gold, thank you
very much, you opened me a door."
Well, what a door because
Michael just answered me
with a zillions more of documents
so I don't have to do any research,
documents are just raining down
my way, a picture of the vessel,
manifest, immigration list, records,
and everything, declaration,
petition, so for sure I had to
do a little bit of homework here.
Now, very fast I started
to learn something
about American immigration
and paperwork.
There is the Declaration of
Intent, which is a court record
and it was done mostly immediately
after arrival for this period,
there is the Petition of Citizenship
that has to have five years
after the person arrived to the
country and requires the witnesses.
Remember the two Singer
guys that signed up?
And then, there is this
Certification of Naturalization
which since 2006, is
centralized by the INS with a form
and the Certificate of
Arrival, which consists
in a fourth document
about this paper trail.
1906 to 1956, this is called C
files and they are all microfilmed.
From 1944 until today
it's called the A files
and those are not microfilmed,
to the best of my knowledge
up until today.
Oh yes, and you can use the
United States CIS.gov research
to find the death certificate or
the certificate for dead people.
This is the family that I put all
together through this paperwork.
You can see over there
David Sattinger
that married Bertha
Sattinger Singer,
father Hein Singer
[assumed spelling].
Of course, remember the two brothers
that married my great-grandparents?
Well, this is a third brother
so yes, we are related,
we have pictures over there.
I have another generation
of immigrants coming here
and then one little guy, the only
and the youngest person
from this family.
Now, I wanted to learn more about
the immigration of this family
so immediately I went to
the Ellis Island database,
the only database I knew about
immigration, the famous database
about immigration and I
typed David Sattinger.
No results.
Hmm, okay so let me look for one
of the second generation,
Herman Sattinger.
Then, I got two Herman Sattingers.
Well, maybe one is my guy in 1920
and the other one is another guy.
Let's start exploring.
Oh yes, to do that you need to
log in and create an account.
Well it's free, no problem, let's
do it and then it will allow you
to actually see the record,
see more information.
You can actually purchase a nice
copy of the immigration record.
Not really my interest, I
have all the text over there,
all the information that I want.
He's single, coming from
Romania, what he speaks,
the vessel that he was
traveling, manifest line number.
Hmm, okay let me see the manifest.
I'm a genealogist, I trust you but
I want to see the records so yeah,
I can right up there
see the ship manifest,
I can see ship information,
annotation, text passenger list.
This is the manifest, here they are,
and again an address in New York.
Now, do you remember
635 North in New York?
That is the information,
the address that was
in the first naturalization
paper that I received
so this guy definitely is
the one that I'm looking for.
Now, what about the
second one, 1950?
We're having only two individuals
here, let's look for it.
I went into the passengers, I
see the document in the registry
and I don't know if you noted
something weird with this record.
First of all 1950, well I didn't
know a lot about American history
by now but probably he came
through Ellis Island in 1950,
but definitely I know
from my childhood
that Pan American World Airlines
was not a ship [laughter].
Well, and then I learned that
although Ellis Island was in charge
of processing all the ships coming
through New York in a period
of time, also kept record
for planes coming to New York
and I learned also that
people were put in buses,
transported from the
airport to Ellis Island,
processed in Ellis Island and that
is the reason why this flight has
his passenger records down there.
Now, this still doesn't answer me
if this is my guy or not but just
by zooming out and reading the
whole list, I can read and see
that this plane came from Venezuela.
Did that ring any bells to you?
Yes, I was born there,
my family was here
so this guy was also there
visiting my family over there.
More than that, because
I'm from Venezuela I know
that the identity cards in Venezuela
numbers are very similar to the one
that is written over there,
starting with a V. It means
that it's a Venezuelan guy but very
interestingly, he was statusless
so the guy came into the
United States in 1920,
it seems never nationalized or got
a residence here in the states,
flew to Venezuela for what I
thought was visiting my family,
got an ID over there, and then
came back to the United States
without any nationality
or citizenship.
Very strange, but definitely
yes, this is my guy.
Now, I decided to go
with a wider search
and look only for the last name.
After all, how many
Sattingers can me?
No worries, I did the same search
for the Singers, very fast came back
to the Sattingers [laughter].
Well, I found also very
interesting information.
You remember Bertha Singer
Sattinger with her daughter Yetti
or Yetta [assumed spelling]
Friedman Sattinger from maiden name?
Here I found those two
ladies coming into America
on the same day, on the same ship.
They must be my people so yup,
for sure I pull out the manifest
from the ship, I see that
they're listed right there.
No other relative,
Sattingers, coming with them.
Of course, then I browse all
these ship manifests for Singer,
Sattinger, or any other related.
No, they came alone.
The mother and the daughter came,
mother was 48, the daughter was 16.
It gave me the address back
in what I said by then Romania
where they are coming
from, everything and just
to make it easier to read, here
you have all the transcription
of the information.
So I decided to use another
search engine and try to look
for Bertha Sattinger and for sure,
I went to the 1930 United States
Federal Census because if she came
in the 20th, the next census for
sure was the 1930 and indeed,
I find here over there listed
with her husband David Sattinger
and I have all the information.
They are still living in
Brooklyn, New York, the district
and the address matches
all the places
that I had from the paperwork.
I could see the census page right
there, David, Bertha, Yetti.
Hmm...do you see who are
below the Sattingers?
They are my Singers so not only
they are related, they are living
at least close enough if
not one on top of the other.
The next step was of
course after 1930, 1940.
No record hmm...strange
things are happening here.
Well, probably they died right?
People die, what can we do so
I wanted to find their graves.
Very famous website, I put over
there the name that I was looking
for and very fast I
get the information
in Mount Hebron Cemetery
in Flushing, Queens.
They stick to New York, good guys.
Of course, very frustrating,
no photo of the tombstone.
I already said I'm a genealogist.
I trust you but I want to see the
records with my own eyes so I found
out the website of
Mount Hebron Cemetery.
They very graciously have a search
engine where I can put the last name
and the first name of the person.
By now, I look only for last
names and not only Bertha,
which you already know, not only
Herman which you already met,
but now we have an Ernestina buried
in if not the exact location very
close, for sure on the same plot
so pretty much sure
this is all my family.
Of course, I see that there is
a link, I try to hit the link.
No images, too bad.
I know I can go to the New
York Department of Records
and ask for a death certificate.
It's really inexpensive, it
has a lot of information,
but there is only one problem and
no, it's not that I'm in Israel
and this is in New York
because through the internet you can
still ask for the records and get it
but it takes time and we
genealogists are very impatient.
we want everything and we
want it now so I did fill that
but in the meantime I went
to other websites to try
to look for more information.
So I go to the birth,
marriage, and death category.
I type by Bertha Sattinger
information, for sure I found her
over there, I found the
find a grave record,
I found Jewish chain information
about her but I also find her
in the death certificate record with
a lot of information but no image.
Okay, at least I am one step further
on my research getting this
information but then I learn
from a friend that all those images
were microfilmed by the Mormons
by Family Search and they are also
available through their catalog.
They have a lot of records.
They also have the census' available
on their website from your house
without any problem but the death
records, those you need to go
to the library in order
to see it and copy them.
So well what's the problem?
Let's go to the library.
I'm fortunate enough to
visit Salt Lake City.
The Family History Library there
is what I consider the Disneyland
for genealogists.
They have over there every
record and every microfilm
that they have ever scanned
and digitized and if not,
because you're asking for a
very rare microfilm, no worries,
you do a petition, in 24 hours
they copy it from their vault
and they bring it up
to you and you can go
and scan it so this is what I did.
I looked for the microfilm and
there are 11 or 12 corridors just
like that, you open the drawer, you
take out the microfilm and you sit
on one of the microfilm readers
and you start making exercise.
Well, very soon I found the page
that I was looking for and faster
than what the New York
Office could give me,
I have the death certificate
of Bertha Sattinger,
married to David Sattinger,
with all the information,
his father Haim Singer from
Austria, her mother maiden name,
and the signature, the address,
everything I know how she died now.
Now, she died, she passed away.
I already know that Herman that you
have over here also passed away.
By the year, I assume
everybody else also passed away
but this has this little
guy down the line,
probably the only living individual
that I know from this family.
So I knew that he was
married with Sara,
he had to be about 65 years
old, maybe living in New York
because if the family didn't move
for so long why he would move?
Well again, I went to Rev
Google, as my son says,
and I type Solo Sattinger,
age approximately 60,
and I came up with this White
Pages website where it tells me
that he lives in 1753 63rd
Street in Brooklyn, New York.
Now how good is your memory?
Did it ring any bells?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, this is the same address
from the naturalization
record that I had before.
Bingo, I have my guy right here.
Now of course, I could
also go to other places
and check his criminal records, his
bank account, and all kind of things
that don't mind for me,
I'm a genealogist not
a private investigator
so I have here all the information.
Now very curiously, they
give me the possible related.
Now, I have no idea who
is Alexandra Sattinger
but look here, Herman pops up again.
Good, I'm on the right track!
Yup, so same Herman that was burned
on the cemetery over there so again,
Google gives me the picture
of the house where he lives
and My Heritage gives
me the opportunity
to travel do New York
and what do I do?
Ding dong.
No, of course I talk first on the
phone and I invite myself yes,
and then I met this wonderful
guy, Solo Sattinger Singer.
He gives me all this information,
he shows me all the pictures.
Of course, he has the very black
and white Singer family picture
that was passed to every descendent,
that was like the sealing
that he belongs to my family
but then he said, "Do
you know Carl Wolf?"
No. Well, this guy Carl Wolf lives
in California and he's a descendent
of someone in the family,
you should contact him.
Of course I'm going to contact
him, give me the phone number.
He gave it to me, I have all the
information so now I'm in New York,
I have some time and I have a car.
What would you do?
Well, my wife will go shopping sure.
I go to the cemetery, remember
Flushing, Queens right there,
my family's waiting
for me so let's go.
And then of course I get to the
cemetery, I go to the office,
I ask for the Sattingers.
They gave me names that are
not listed on the website,
the names that they have
on the website are not
listed in the office.
Very clearly they have no idea who
they have buried over there and then
of course they tell me
well you know, it's 4:15
and we close the cemetery at five.
If you're not out by five, you
will need to jump the fence.
Well that's not a problem but the
car is going to be a little bit
of a challenge so I have two
options, either go to the plot
and look for my relative and then
take pictures for the cemetery
of the tombstones or
pull out my smartphone,
pull out my billion
graves application,
and start taking pictures of
every tombstone that I see.
Now, this is not the
first time that I do this,
I normally do this in Israel.
I can do between 400
and 450 tombstones
in an hour very easy, very fast.
I will strongly suggest you to
try it so I have about 40 minutes
to take pictures and
take my car out of there.
I run into the whole area,
I don't read the tombstones,
I just make sure I capture
all the stone in the picture,
I surround the stone, make sure
that there's nothing on the sides,
I take out a little
bit of the bushes.
Now this is my first experience
also with a US cemetery
and this is the first time
that I see all this pillars
and the entrance of the plot
and I learned a little bit
of how Jewish groups
bought this piece of land
and they made a collaborative
office to put money into it
and benefit everybody over there.
And there I start,
afterwards of course back home,
I start reading those names and
do you see those names over there?
Singer, Singer, Max Singer, Max
restauranteur, also here involved
in the community and of
course, after I looked
into my pictures I have
over the Bertha Sattinger,
I have David Abram Sattinger, I
have Herman, we already know him
but then I have Regina, I have
Sally, I have Joseph, I have Enya,
I have everybody or almost
everybody in my family over there.
Of course, now if I go into Billion
Graves, I can look for more records,
I can find other people buried
not only in that cemetery but also
in other ones and they very
great advantage is that if I want
to go back, because remember
I just took pictures,
I had no idea where the
location of this stone was.
I have the picture with the
information on the Billion Graves,
it will mark exactly the geolocation
of that stone so next week when I'm
in New York, guess
what I'm going to do?
Yes, I'm going to visit
the cemetery and I'm going
to light a candle in those stones.
Now, back to Carl Wolf.
Who was this guy?
Well, you already knew my
great-grand uncle Haim Singer
so he had a daughter Hencia Singer,
you just saw her tombstone right
there so she had also a couple
of sons and daughters and I realized
that I was actually
missing one person here.
They have a third kid, a girl
in this kid, Sally Singer Wolf.
She married Jacob Wolf
and they had a son,
Carl Wolf so let's get
in touch with this guy.
I phone him, he's in
California, I woke him up.
Yes, there's a time
difference between New York
and California [laughter].
Curious the things you
learn with genealogy.
He was very gracious to
give me all the information.
Look how beautiful my
family tree looks now.
I have pictures, I have dates,
I have places, I have everything
over there and of course I
have more people to research.
And then, I went to the United
States Holocaust Memorial Museum
because I learned that all
these people didn't leave
with the other part of the
family, they were in the Holocaust.
They were survivors of
the Second World War
and they were registered
somehow, or at least I thought,
in the Holocaust Museum Memorial
and there's another place
which I definitely
encourage you to research.
The only caveat here is that for
better research you should do it
physically and there's
only 11 countries,
meaning 11 places where
you can do that.
Well, actually 12, in Israel
we cheat a little bit.
In Israel, you should
go to Yad Vashem,
which is the Holocaust
Museum over there
but what not everybody knows is that
the Jerusalem one everybody knows,
huge museum, huge research over
there but there's another branch
in a little city called [inaudible]
and over there you can go of course,
nothing like the Library of
Congress but they have computers
and they have access to
this database and for sure,
I went here in Washington
and I found Joseph Singer
with Henya Singer in a
collection named over there.
Now, these are what they
call DP camp cards meaning,
after the war people
went to these camps.
They were catalogued, they were
recorded, not only themselves
but also the people that
were together in the family
so here I learned that Joseph
Singer was also accompanied
by Nora Malley Wolf Jacob hmm,
name starts to appear,
Regina and [inaudible].
I found also the dates
match, the people match.
I found the Nora Singer hmm.
Same date okay, that's weird but
that's a name I have and then
of course I went back to
immigration records because I knew
that they died here and I found
an Anora Singer so it's Henya,
it's Nora, it's Anora [assumed
spellings] or depending the day
of the week she changed her name or
probably somebody typed it wrong,
but the dates all were together
the same, the address was the same
so definitely yes,
this is my relative
so keep an eye on the names.
Names change and I'm not
taking about last names,
I'm talking about first names.
So, I have my family here
and if you see the people
that accompany this Joseph
Singer guy I see Jacob and Sally,
just as my family tree and Carl
gave it to me and I found Beryl,
Tepera and Regina [assumed
spellings] right there,
and I found the cards
for the Hollenberg family
and Beryl and Tepera right there.
Regina Tepera you remember from the
cemetery that I took the picture.
Now Beryl, it's totally a mystery.
He was not buried over there.
I haven't been able to find
him in any other cemetery.
Nobody knows what happened and
if you see and if you notice,
there is a discrepancy
with the last name.
He left Europe with the name
Hollenberg and he was recorded
in the United States
with the name Tepera.
Hm.. this is a mysterious guy.
If you see it somewhere
around please let me know,
I'm still looking for him.
Now of course, the more
information I put in my family tree,
the more records, the more
matches, the more connections I do
with other people and
with other families.
My Heritage is very useful for
pointing me in the right direction
and of course, I don't
take anything for granted.
I like to see the records
so I go over
and I researched all those
collections right here
and this is only a sample
of the US collections
where my family is recorded.
This is a sample of Bertha Singer
and Sattinger, how they appear.
You can see the pictures, you
can see other family trees
that also have the same information.
Most of them, my own cousins
that are stealing my information
but I'm fine with it as long as
they said it's coming from me.
Now, I also have another branch of
my family that I would like to share
with you and this is
the Menchel family.
Now, this family came a little
bit earlier to the United States
and a little bit different
records and experience here.
Of course, I'm already kind of an
expert with immigration records
in the United States, I know
the index back and forth,
I know the numbers and I very
easily find Tessie Menchel and only
because she was registered with
her married last name of course,
because otherwise I
would never find her.
Well, this is the Petition
of Naturalization,
you already know those type
of documents and if I zoom in,
you can see that she
was known as Pese Grun.
That's why I said I would never
find her if she was not kind enough
to mention in the same
document that [inaudible]
and Tessie Menchel is actually
the same person and of course,
a wealth of information
again for me.
I have dates, I have
places, I have addresses.
I'm not surprised already Bronx,
New York, the same streets,
the same places but I have
here also the kids, Donald no,
not that one this is another one
and the other one Sidney yes,
thanks you yes Sidney and
Donald with their birth dates
and all the information so let's
look more into Pese Grun now,
I know the name she came before
and I have the immigration record
and this is another
wealth of information.
I have Pese Grun and I can see that
somebody wrote over there Green,
and at certain point somebody
decided to correct it to Grun,
Grun/Green is actually
the same thing.
It all depends on the
language and the pronunciation
and I find more people here.
Pese was 18, was a child when
she arrived with the mother 48,
but she had also two siblings over
there and if I scroll to the side
of the record, I find
actually more information.
I know Tessie's grandfather
Lev Green,
I told you Green/Grun
is the same thing.
He was left back in Poland, I guess
alive for this time of the year.
Of course all these numbers,
I'm already an expert.
It means all the naturalization and
petition so I can go to the index
and I can get all the
information from there.
Now remember that she was
married to Abram Menchel
and of course I found him in the
1940 census with all the information
where he lived, the relatives and
everybody over there and I found
that Sidney in 1940, was 14
years old and Donald was seven.
Now I'm very bad with math but I
can tell you that if they were 14
and seven, especially
Sidney in 1940,
by the time of the war he was
already available for military duty.
So, I went to the National
Archive because I heard
that they had a wonderful collection
of military records so I scan
over there, I read
all the information,
I make a few phone calls, send a
few emails and very fast I found
that indeed Sidney Menchel
was in the military since 31
of October 1943, until at
least 31 of January 1945.
What he did, he was a raider
operator and he was stationed here
in the United States so he never
went back to Europe to fight.
Now if I am already in New
York, I don't know how many
of you have the knowledge of this,
Risen Initiative, Reclaim
the Records.
New York and other places are being
requested to submit those indexes
to make them pubically available.
My very good friend I have to share,
Brook Ganz [inaudible] she
is managing this initiative,
getting the images
transcribed and available
to everybody on the internet.
She received a few years directly on
digital so she made this search page
where I just put Donald Menchel, I
heard that he was married to Barbara
and there she is right
on the first line,
Barbara Winograd [assumed
spelling] with Donald Menchel,
married in Brooklyn
1957, and how wonderful!
This record is more than 50
years so it's actually open
and I already filed a petition
to get a copy of the certificate.
Now of course, I have many, many
more family in the United States
but my time is limited
because I have a job,
because I have another
family to take care of
and because I'm traveling a lot
but don't worry, I'm pretty sure
that with a little help of the
technology and with a little help
of other genealogists and
researchers, I will be able
to keep track of all this family,
all these events that happen
across the United States and for
sure my very most excited dream is
to keep traveling and
keep visiting family
and knowing those different
people over there.
Now, here are the techniques to
research data I would like you
to adopt, or suggestions.
First, build your family tree
especially with good technology.
I have no problem if you start with
a pen and paper but move as fast
as you can to a good technology.
Contact and interview
your relatives.
Those that you already know please,
make phone calls, send emails,
the sooner the better
because you know people,
as I said, life is short.
Travel the country.
Well, if you can, enjoy.
If not, internet is still a good
way to at least virtually traveling.
Google has not only a search engine
but also the places, the Google Maps
that you can see where
your relative lived.
Try to encourage family reunion,
which is what I do in every place
that I'm going, try to contact
my family and gather together
to have more information.
Share and collaborate with
them, tell them what you know,
tell them what you don't know,
and I'm pretty sure they are going
to start telling you stories and
facts that you never heard before.
It's also very convenient
to invite them afterwards
to the family tree so they can see.
Depending on how many individuals
you have in your family tree,
depending on how much information
you have researched you can either
allow them to touch and collaborate.
In my case, 7,000 individuals
and more than 30 years
of research, nobody touches it.
You want to add something
not a problem, send it to me
and I will be more than happy
not only to add it but also
with the proper source citation,
this was given to me by this person,
on this date, in this way.
And last thing for sure,
subscribe to forums
and shout out your research.
Every time you have the opportunity,
every time you have a gathering,
tell everybody the last names,
the names, your brick walls,
the things that you're researching.
You never know, as it was
said already at the beginning
of the presentation, you
never know from where
and how your brick wall is going
to be broken and you're going
to discover a wonderful wealth
of information over there.
So thank you very, very much
for having me here again.
Now, you have also met
my US Jewish family.
I really hope that you picked on
some of the tips and the research
that I have done and you
can apply to your family
and hopefully you also will find
a lot of your family members.
Thank you very, very much and I can
answer any question that you want.
Yes, go ahead.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes sir?
>> I noticed you didn't mention
the Jewish online burial records
and you didn't mention [inaudible].
Have you had any-
>> The question was that
I didn't mention the JOBAR
or Jewish World Burial
Records and JewishGen-
>> No, Jewish Data.
>> Jewish Data, that's a separate
website so let's focus first.
Jewish Data, that's an easy
one yes, it's a website
that collects Jewish
information for sure,
it's subscribed, it's
a paid membership.
Some societies some
places have it for fee.
I did research over there
including the Library of Congress,
didn't know that, thank you
very much for letting me know.
I did search over there but didn't
find unfortunately I would say a lot
of good stuff.
Yes, I found the burials
and the places but no images
and just the numbers or the places
depending for the cemeteries.
Now, JewishGen and the Jewish World
Burial Records Project again yes,
I did find a little bit over
there, not always with images.
I mentioned actually I did mention
JewishGen when I was searching
through Ancestry because
there is a partnership
and in Ancestry you can find
records from over there.
The only reason that I
didn't mention it here was
because of how I built
my presentation.
I for sure used them and
have a few pieces and beads
of my family gathered from there.
>> Abraham Lubble [phonetic]
is putting on gravestones
on Jewish Data and I'm learning, if
we're talking about the same thing,
any time we find information
about graves on Jewish Data,
there will be a photograph
about the grave.
>> Okay so the comment is
that photos are being
placed in Jewish Data.
You mentioned the creator of
the website Abraham Lubble,
I'm familiar with him and again, I
didn't mention a lot of other places
and websites available over there.
I have to be constrained on the time
of the presentation but even more
than that just go ahead and
Google, you will find a lot
of other resources there.
Yes?
>> You mentioned family reunions.
Have you had a family
reunion with US family?
>> I mention family
reunions and yes,
I had one in New York
with the Menchels.
Actually, one of the
cousins lives here in DC
and I will meet him today.
Then yes, Carl Wolf, of course
I met him also in California.
Interesting fact, I didn't find
Carl's mother's burial although
by that time she was 102, and the
reason is because today she is 104
and kicking so yes, every place I
go I try to meet with my family.
Unfortunately there has not been a
huge United States family reunion,
distance here is quite big,
but definitely I would encourage
you to contact everyone.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> So the question is how, if and
where I document all the stories
that I get from the families
so yes, the first thing
that I do is I ask permission
and immediately I pulled this small
device where we used to make calls
with it so now I use it to record
video and audio the conversations
and then I go over it and I
transcribe the pieces and the data
that I collect for the
family tree for the facts
but I also have the digital
recording uploaded to the website
and then I tag that recording
with the people mentioned
in that recording.
The next step of course will be
to transcribe the whole
conversation and the whole history.
Normally, software and
websites have places to do that.
You have other websites
and other software
that are specially dedicated
into family history recording
and you can use them.
It all depends on what do
you feel comfortable with
and you should try a
few and you should work
with whatever feels more
comfortable but definitely record,
save, and share for sure.
Yes madam?
>> Did you finally get an identity
for every person in this picture?
>> Finally yes for sure, I have
the names and the relationship
of everyone in this family
including that little baby boy
that actually gave me the year and
the date that the picture was taken.
Yes indeed, thank you.
Yes madam?
>> Were you able to find out
which of your family died
in the Holocaust in Europe?
>> Family that died in the Holocaust
yes, both the Holocaust Museum here
in Washington, both Vad
Vashem also in Israel
which you can very easily
access through the website,
they have pages of
testimony over there.
I found the people that perished
over there mostly reported
by those survivors but yes, I could
go a little bit further into Europe
and again, thankful enough I also
visited the places where we lived
and managed to gather
the information firsthand
from there so yes, it is possible.
>> [Inaudible] family in
the states with DNA tests?
>> If my family have taken a
DNA test, of course they did
and you know how was
the second person?
Remember that 104 year old lady,
well she suffers Alzheimer's,
she has no idea who she is
and why this guy was trying
to open her mouth to scrub her inner
cheek but yes, we have her DNA,
we have Carl Wolf's DNA as well
and I'm encouraging everybody
in my family to take a DNA test.
The DNA has proven that this is
really my family just in case
with all of the paperwork was not
enough, yes I found relationship
between second cousins twice
removed and all of this kind
of difficult relationships
proven by DNA
so yes definitely another resource.
Yes madam.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> The number of the
family members I have found?
Well, my family tree has now 7,000
individuals, a little bit more
than 7,000 individuals but
I cheated a little bit.
I had also to put boundaries.
If somebody marries
into the family I may
or may not put their
parents and that's it.
For example, you saw the
example of Tessie Green.
I have her although I
don't have the records,
I don't have her grandparents
or the siblings
and it's just more a
personal choice than other.
I would say probably a couple
hundred I found through research
with documents, interviews
and immediate family members I
didn't know, although the big part
of the family I knew from
my childhood in Venezuela.
Yes please?
>> Thank you very much
this is very exciting.
I had a question, where does Mr.
Horowitz come in because you talk
about the Singers and the Sattingers
but you didn't go into Horowitz.
>> Where does my Horowitz come from?
My Horowitz came from the town of
Chernowicz, same as the Singers.
Actually, my grandfather Horowitz
married my grandmother Singer
in Chernowicz, but then
they immigrated either
to Venezuela or to Israel.
They were not in the United States.
I also have done a lot of
extensive research about them
in Chernowicz, in Venezuela,
in Israel.
A branch also went with
my Uncle Lotter to England
and I have found it over there
but for some reason they
didn't come to United States.
One more question and I can
stay for later on if you want.
Yes madam.
>> Do you have a resource for
those organizations that you find
when the gates to a
cemetery, the name-
>> A research for the
organizations on the cemeteries?
I will suggest JewishGen for sure.
JewishGen has an extensive list
of burial societies and plots
that were bought for
these societies.
There is a word in German
[inaudible] thank you very much,
it escaped my mind.
That's the word that you are going
to look for the, the [inaudible]
but yes, just Google JewishGen, they
should bring you the information.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Excellent, it was mentioned
the [inaudible] Institute
in New York has a list of all this.
There are really multiple
lists of resources out there.
I just took a very few, the ones
that gave me the most amount
of information in my research
and the most interesting pieces
for my research but definitely you
cannot leave any stone unturned
to find your relative.
Thank you very, very
much again for being here
and enjoy the rest of your day.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.